E aí
[Música]
a coisa se tem uma coisa que me desse
arretada revoltada é o seu tomar conta
de minha vida porque eu vou dizer um
negócio para você viu misericórdia meu
Deus então eu aqui na minha casa fazendo
meu almoço esperando meu marido
esperando meu filho chegar me toca na
porta eu olhei que eu mando segundo
andar e olhei pela janela disse oi o
rapaz me falou Dona responde aqui para
mim só uma pergunta rapidinha coisas
rápida para o meu trabalho desse falei
vou responder aí beleza foi responder
ele ele disse para mim a primeira
pergunta quantas pessoas que mora dentro
da sua casa antes que eu respondesse
Berenice estava lá do outro lado no
portão da casa dela já foi logo gritando
olha quanto pessoas é o marido mandou os
filhos eu olhei assim Você não perguntou
não foi para mim tá letra aí ele fez
outra pergunta aí quanto que ganha cada
um aqui dentro da casa da senhora Eu fiz
a benção para poder responder perene
escrita do outro lado ela
se você trabalhar dentro de casa o
marido ganha um salário mínimo hoje mas
eu fiquei com tanta raiva eu fiquei com
tanto ódio que eu mirei naquela mulher
ali ó se eu tivesse podendo meus olhos
eu tinha de subir daquela mulher no
portão da casa dela como é que ela sabe
quanto meu marido ganha aí beleza fiz
assim com o dedo mostrando para ele que
ela tava certa aí ele pegou e se essa
terceira pergunta animal tem na casa da
senhora a dita cuja respondeu do outra
tem ouvido um besta de dormir vamos
espero eu falei ó menino é só Mesmo
bebendo água com açúcar você fica aí com
essa jornalista porque ela sabe mais da
Vida da Gente do que azeite mesmo não
aguento não é só me hidratando
e quando olhei até bem
é igual fogueira
em São João eu perguntei a Deus do céu
Por que tamanha judiação
[Música]
e eu perguntei a Deus do céu
é porque amanhã
o judiação
e eu perguntei a Deus do céu Por que
tamanha judiação
e essa minha personagem safroa reguilida
criada 21 anos é sempre assim fala alto
Alegre tudo ela quer resolver no grito
tudo ela acha que está certa mas ela é
gente boa antes de falar dessa flor é
importante dizer que já trabalho com
teatro a 24 anos Aliás a personagem só
existe por causa do teatro eu sempre
digo o teatro transformou a vida desse
menino que antes era tímido
e essa personagem ela mudou muito a
minha vida
e esse personagem ele transformou vidas
mas antes é preciso dizer desse menino
fazendo esse teatro e se descobrindo e
essa personagem só existe por causa do
teatro Foi por causa dele que ela está
aqui hoje
Oi e esse menino é filho de pais
separados desde os 6 anos de idade
o e aprendeu a tendo que dividir que de
segunda a quinta-feira ele era da mãe e
de sexta a domingo do pai e foi cedo
também que esse menino aprendeu é o que
seria advogado juiz Afinal foram tantas
audiências esse menino era tão disputado
mas com o tempo ele foi se acostumando
com aquilo e foi crescendo desenvolvendo
Mas aquela timidez excessiva aquele medo
de falar em público ainda tava com
aquele menino
e foi então que aos 14 anos ele
participou de uma peça de teatro na
escola por coincidência porque foi
empurrado e olha que se não fosse aquela
gincana de geografia aquele menino
jamais teria feito teatro
bom e depois daquele dia tudo que tinha
na escola todas as atividades esse
menino queria fazer com teatro esse
menino queria mostrar sua arte o
mosquitinho ali tinha picado ele o
mosquitinho da arte
e foi então que as professoras deram
conselhos para ele diz para ele vai
procurar um teatro de bairro para você
fazer para poder mudar vai te ajudar e
muito
e com ajuda da minha tia Procurei um
teatro de bairro ingressei bem Passaram
seis meses para aquele menino tímido já
era passou foi embora tchau graças a
Deus o teatro tava mudando a minha vida
é a mas não tô esperando a minha vida
menino pelo amor de Deus Eu vim aqui
e foi para fugir calma essa flor calma
minha filha a sua vida é a mesma que a
minha
a minha mãe trabalhava viajando e quem
cuidava de mim era minha avó Dona
Anastácia essa assim adorava trabalhar
dentro de casa mas ela não abrirá mão de
ir para a porta da rua todos os dias à
tarde conversar com suas amigas as
vizinhas e sentada lá na porta elas
diziam a gente senta aqui é para poder
espairecer a cabeça da gente eu sei ela
queria mesmo era tomar conta Ltda Rua
ver o que que é que tava acontecendo
minha vó ela sempre escutava o mesmo a
mesma música Era no mesmo radinho aquela
fita sempre era presente ali junto com a
gente a música Asa Branca
e quando olhei a terra ardendo igual
fogueira de São João eu perguntei a Deus
do céu vai por que tamanha judiação
a saudade dela mas tamanha judiação aí
eu cantando aqui para vocês né esse
nunca foi um do meu cantar mas essa
música ia mudar minha vida depois
daquele dia uma frase que aquela vizinha
da minha avó ia soltar também ia mudar
minha vida porque olhando uma galinha
com seus pintinhos ali no outro quintal
ela olhou mijou naqueles pintinhos e
falou para minha avó passa piseza a
cabeça do pintinho tá tudo pelada vendo
aquela frase aquele me chamou atenção
Oi e eu comecei a fazer aquela imitação
daquela frase como era uma senhora muito
conhecida chamava Dona cota todo mundo
sabia maneira que ela conversava e
quando me enviam fazendo aquilo sempre
pedia para repetir a cabeça do pintinho
piu é
a minha tia também adorava essa imitação
no entanto adorar que o meu tio foi
casar Ela disse o seguinte olha eu tive
uma ideia você vai entrar na igreja e
quando o padre disse assim é quem aqui
que é contra esse casamento Você vai
entrar você tem coragem de vestir essa
personagem porque vocês são imita com a
voz tem coragem de vestir falei tenho a
gente vai fazendo aí algumas coisas a
gente inventa e tudo mais
E você tem coragem de entrar na igreja e
prestar esse papel eu falei meu sonho já
trabalho com teatro e para mim o que é
um prato cheio você acha que se der
certo
é claro que não né gente a noiva do meu
tio tava do lado escutando essa conversa
toda ela falou que não na minha no meu
no meu casamento eu vou entrar não
imagina o que que é que o padre não vai
fazer não vai pensar de mim mas deu uma
solução ali se vocês quiserem apresentar
na festa vocês podem fazer alguma coisa
então minha tinha um pouco já queria
criar nome para essa personagem isso
aqui já era pouco já era pequeno para
ela ela queria fazer o quê uma
personagem gigantesca que tivesse peruca
que tivesse roupas que tivessem ali uma
aparência e convidou todos os primos
para poder participar dessa peça e
escreveu e no dia do casamento a gente
apresentou essa peça e foi um sucesso
500 convidados assistindo a gente
naquela festa de casamento eu não sei
onde que meu tio arranjou o dinheiro
para poder pagar tanta comida porque ela
gente mas arranjou
é daquele dia eu comecei a ter um sonho
porque aquela personagem ela aparecia
com esses programas humorísticos de TV
canal grande aberta e eu queria muito
entrar nesse programa Era meu sonho
Oi e aí eu comecei a apresentar essa
personagem em muitos lugares asilos
festas qualquer coisa que tivesse aqui
me chamasse eu apresentava essa
personagem a ponto de me apresentar para
o mundo o que tinha tomado aquele gosto
e naquela época 21 anos atrás Um homem
vestido de mulher poderia causar um
estranha poderia Não causavam estranha
né
Ah e eu tinha medo muitos artistas
trabalhavam de transformistas naquela
época mas eu não queria ser daquele
jeito porque eu tinha vergonha eu tinha
medo de fazer aquilo
bom então eu decidi colocar a personagem
caricata né é um blush excessivo um
batom grandes né umas umas roupas
exageradas
e para que eu pudesse passar por aquilo
e hoje muitos artistas que estão aí na
mídia fazendo sucesso com o mesmo
trabalho que eu faço eles precisam
agradecer muito a esses artistas que
deram a cara a tapa muito tempo atrás
mas eu não desisti também não eu queria
era entrar nesse programa Famoso então
eu comecei a entrar em cursos de teatro
entrar em vários grupos apresentaram a
minha personagem para todo mundo até que
um dia eu recebi um telefonema de um
rapaz que trabalhava numa emissora de tv
local aqui em Montes Claros então ele
falou para mim no telefone Oi tudo bom
Beleza eu falei joia ele disse olha a
gente assistiu uma sua personagem no
teatro aí e a gente queria fazer um
teste com você para você fazer uma
participação em um programa da gente
você aceita eu respondi ensina a hora
não
E também o telefone falei meu Deus do
céu muito obrigado meu Deus está
acontecendo o senhor Jesus obrigado meu
Deus tá bom e TV fechar errada você ver
aqui local mas é um degrau primeiro a
cada vez hoje é o canal local amanhã eu
tô Nacional não tem problema
Oi me responde aí para ele você me dá só
um minuto para poder conferir na minha
agenda para ver se eu tenho
disponibilidade hoje gente eu não fazia
nada naquela época eu só estudava mas eu
tinha um sonho de falar para alguém que
eu ia conferir na agenda Então eu tinha
que usar aquela oportunidade eu não
sabia Quando que é que eu ia voltar com
aquilo aí eu virei para ele falei hora
tenho disponibilidade sim que dia que
você quer ele falou dia 10/8 horas da
noite eu já saí correndo e correndo
contando para todo mundo minhas vizinhas
lote já foi lá para casa né não tá na
porta de casa no dia que eles foram me
buscar fizeram cartazes ficaram tudo lá
esperando porque naquela época microfone
e câmera se hoje já faz um alvoroço todo
naquela época então povo desesperava e
nem as vizinhas vendo aquele povo chegar
lá para me buscar Começou a cantar ele é
a o delícia essa flor vai gravar a rima
que era bom nada
Oi e eu morrendo de vergonha
eu entrei naquele carro fingindo costume
como se aquilo ali né fizesse parte de
minha vida como se já fosse artista como
se aquilo eu trabalhasse há muito tempo
e deixei elas lá passando vergonha
o e fui apresentei Fiz aquele programa
Gravei aquele programa junto com meu
parceiro executou
o e daquele dia em diante eu passei no
teste e estou nesse programa até hoje
muitas coisas mudaram de lá para cá
graças a esse programa eu também
realizei outro sonho meu que era de
trabalhar numa rádio porque esse pessoal
da Rádio me assistiram no programa e me
convidaram para poder fazer e não sabia
eles que era um dos meus maiores sonhos
também
é mas é uma trajetória muito bonita
é mas tem também as suas dificuldades
e muitas portas foram fechadas para mim
muitos nãos eu recebi muito difícil
chegar até aqui uma vida de um artista
que tem que às vezes deixar de comer
para poder comprar um sapato e tem que
deixar de comprar certas vezes um gás
para poder investir em uma peruca a
ponto de fazer daquela peruca o gás logo
depois
com tantas dificuldades que me fez parar
e pensar chega eu não quero mais fazer
isso eu não estou disposto a fazer isso
e eu não quero não tenho mais eu esgotei
e quantas vezes que eu tava me maquiando
e eu pensei gente quantos projetos meus
que estão parados sem eu poder resolver
É mas eu não esqueci daquelas portas que
foram fechadas porque estavam fechadas
mas muitas janelas foram abertas e eu
pulei Eu também não posso deixar de
agradecer quem abriu aquela janelas para
mim eu pulei pulei com gosto e por causa
dessa janelas abertas e por causa da
minha atitude Eu Venci hoje eu posso
dizer para você que eu venci eu consegui
trabalhar com que eu gosto e consegui me
manter drag homem vestido de mulher
o personagem chame como quiser mas o
fato que
e o que é safroa reguilida proporcionou
para minha vida foi extraordinário hoje
eu posso dizer para vocês que eu consigo
pagar as contas de casa consigo
retribuir para minha mãe tudo que ela
fez por mim
e hoje eu consigo olhar para trás e ver
nossa lutei muito lutei lutei mesmo e tô
conseguindo colher Tudo que Eu Plantei
não foi fácil até aqui muito chegam até
a mim
bom e fala que querem fazer a mesma
coisa muito chegam até a mim fala Nossa
o seu trabalho muda minha vida os seus
vídeos me alegra você é minha terapia
sem saber eles que eles também a minha
então eu paro e penso tá vendo aí você
não vai parar não você vai continuar e é
por isso que eu tô aqui hoje a arte
mudou a minha vida e eu espero que se
você e do outro lado tem vontade de ser
artista que ela pode mudar a sua também
e essa vida desse menino antes muito
tímido que conseguiu virar um artista
que esse sonho foi realizado porque eu
ainda não entrei naquele programa lá
famoso de TV e pode ser que eu nem entre
já disse
É mas o sonho de ser um artista eu
consegui realizar
Oi e eu espero que a minha história pode
transformar a sua vida hoje a safroa
reguilida é assim porque ela passou por
muitas transformações assim como Cada um
de você passa na sua vida
bom e você vai vencer basta descruzar os
braços e ir atrás eu tenho muito orgulho
de estar aqui hoje muito mesmo para
poder mostrar para vocês o outro lado da
moeda Prazer Leo Ribeiro
e quando olhei a terra ardendo igual
fogueira de São João eu perguntei a Deus
do céu ai por que tamanha judiação